all right well thanks very much for the
introduction um and uh what we're here
to talk about today is um something we
announced two weeks ago called P cell
technology it's funny it it it sort of
leaked out a little bit on expectedly
two years ago cuz I was giving a talk at
Colombia and I didn't um I should know a
little bit more about the web and
everything else but I didn't realize I
was giving a lecture that was going to
be broadcast over the internet and they
asked for something new we were working
on in the lab that not released yet and
I I liked unlike a lot of the work you
know that's done where you you kind of
have what you is a significant advance
and you kind of publish it and then
refin and so forth it gets released to
commercial um or standards buys Etc and
then they go and uh polish it up and
release it in some form the usual way
that I do my work is that we develop
everything kind of like a startup and
expect to release it and have it so it
can be released commercially you know
hopefully within a year and so that was
the case with this but since it got out
we released a very very vague uh white
paper about Dao Dido distributed input
distributed output technology without
getting into any of the Practical issues
and so forth just sort of explaining
more than the few slides I had in that
uh talk so now that we have it out uh
we've been just kind of overwhelmed with
people that are uh uh interested in it
and um so we've been working on another
wi paper which is much more detailed
goes into a lot more of the uh
technology and so forth uh but we are
just doing non-stop demos so we had hop
to maybe do a demo here but we just
couldn't get into the room uh in advance
because of all the classes but I'd like
to say even before uh I start out on the
talk is that um we don't really have
anything we want to hide here no one's
trying to some of the stuff are pretty
significant advances okay and uh they
deserve to be uh very closely uh you
know examined um so for example I would
invite people people from Stanford
you're just in our backyard I we're we
did most of the work actually in
paloalto then we moved up to San
Francisco um to come up maybe get a
group of people want to get a demo dig
in really see what the thing looks like
it's too bad we don't have a demo here
right but anyways I have some videos of
demos all right and very happy to go and
uh show you what we've got so so this is
the uh uh company um there's me as uh
you know you just heard I either you
could say that uh I've been doing a lot
of different things you could say I
haven't been able to hold down a job
either one is I I suppose equally true
um but my background you know I way back
when developed QuickTime technology web
TV which I guess maybe the significance
of web TV was that we just show that the
web could be used on something other
than a computer you know what I mean um
but in any case that uh I got acquired
by Microsoft built their campus here we
developed all their television and uh uh
television related products uh I did
color Macintosh I just did a cloud
gaming company and so forth Anon friends
a PhD uh is the principal scientist he
worked with me for eight and a half
years on this and uh he got his degree
at U UT Austin I started working with
him when he was finishing up his PhD and
I had gone around to a lot of people
then with the idea with the simulation
and uh people just turned me away
they're saying that you know some uh I
don't know what you learned in your
first year of electrical engineering
says a lot of the things you're trying
to do here are just not going to work
and one Professor I I remember because I
thought it actually a reasonably
sophisticated thing I was putting in
there uh he said who put you up to this
and so uh but anyways when I contacted
Antonio we were able to go and uh he
said he saw it really as a challenge he
kind of analyzed the point where he said
that there some s there's a few things
that we're doing that are quite
different than had been done before and
he wanted to go figure it out and work
with me make it a practical system um he
was at iOS span you know with Paul Raj
here and uh Raycom Samsung free scale he
has a great background Roger terrific
guy for just putting together every
imagable kind of basic technology you
know the early algorithms for Moa facial
capture it's used for Gravity recently
but Harry Potter you know whever C into
was face curious Cas of Benjamin Button
and on live um and Cindy Ivor is
actually the audience here who kind of
holds the whole place together um here's
the team okay so let's talk uh we
started this thing talking about that I
tend to uh dip my toe into things that
are big well okay let's look at mobile
operator revenues uh here's very recent
numbers 2013 um mobile operator
reverence are $ 1.2 trillion doar US
Dollars worldwide uh they expect that to
grow to$ 1.4 trillion doar by 2020 now
given the amount of infrastructure
everything else they plan to put in
there that's a pretty small increase
actually as you can see they see the
overall uh mobile EOS ecosystem at 2
trillion last year and growing to 2.9
trillion and the reason they see
operator Revenue not growing that much
is they see that the world is becoming
more of a commodity world you know uh
you know with LTE being everywhere uh
even you know a T-Mobile can effectively
uh compete very well against an AT&T and
affect their prices and so on because
everyone's selling more or less the same
thing they do see big growth in apps and
content and advertising and then these
numbers don't add up to these numbers
and everything in between the
infrastructure the devices and so forth
adds up to these very very large numbers
and um of course uh all these numbers
are those big numbers are driving huge
growth we've already seeing that this is
a chart from Ericson uh last year and
one things that's I find really
interesting about this chart is you can
this pretty much tells you why uh the
early adopters of Lte were FDD adopters
as opposed to tdd adopters the yellow
bars there show the growth that we've
seen in data from voice traffic and this
is really what they had in mind back in
the early 2000s when they're planning
the networks that are deployed today no
one imagined that they' see this massive
explosion of data growth which started
with the iPhone get Amplified when you
know Android was introduced um actually
around the same time as the iPhone but
when Verizon adopted Android and really
said hey we're going to get behind this
thing then it really began to contribute
to the huge growth there and then with
the iPad and uh as you can see this
growth as they see Contin to 2013 they
expect to grow well beyond that so
here's again Eric said again um and you
can see 2013 is where we are now look
where they expect them to be everything
to be in 2018 what's nice about this
chart they begin to show how it's broken
up and you can see that it's highly
asymmetric um you know the vast majority
of it is well or more than half of it is
video alone then we look at things like
web browsing web browsing is a lot of
video I mean you go to website video
comes in and there's other mostly uh you
know Downstream activities sure there's
FaceTime and Skype and things like that
that are symmetric but the vast majority
of uh what we're seeing now is highly
asymmetric we actually have this sanet
thing it's a really cool analyzer and
you put up in San Francisco and you can
listen into AT&T Verizon their downlink
channel is saturated the Uplink channel
is empty okay we're already seeing 8:1
10:1 in the US um and I think it's going
to be pinning there because you need a
certain amount of Uplink just to be able
to do the down link right and uh they
just there's no more down link to be had
um but look at this explosive growth so
then you take Cisco's numbers again just
released in
February and so if we if we make it 1X
in
2013 By 2020 we're talking out 20x the
amount of data traffic that we have
today 7 years from now
20x and uh so does anyone see any
problem with this graph okay well here's
the problem okay seriously I mean how
can we possibly handle 27x the amount of
data traffic on mobile and the thing
it's funny about this is sometimes what
happens you have analysts who are going
and taking this assumption and then
building other conclusions from it that
$2.9
trillion this is the foundation that
it's built on top of okay they they're
tacitly assuming that there is a way to
increase the capacity of current
networks by a factor of 27 let's go back
that means networks that have been built
since the beginning of time for cellular
are now increase by a factor of 27 okay
by
2020 meanwhile you've got all sorts of
things we'll talk about this even 10x in
our view it's beyond what you can
physically accomplish using cellular
technology we're already at a point of
overload in major markets and it's
getting worse and it starts with being
out of spectrum um I showed this chart
here uh two years ago when was released
by the
FCC everyone agreed with the upper bars
about the growth but it's funny nobody
believed about the bars going down here
that by 2013 we'd actually have places
where we could not meet the demands um
given the spectrum that had been
allocated thus far and it wasn't until L
McAdam the C Verizon followed by a CFO
had to make disclosures to their
investors saying that hey we cannot meet
the needs in our major markets of New
York Chicago San Francisco Dallas I
believe unless and the reason we can is
because of a physics limit now how often
do you see a CEO of a major corporation
talk about physics to investors okay he
basically essentially what we're saying
and this is confirmed by you know the
work they've done they tried everything
they've tried all the different Advanced
modes they looked at with LTE they've
tried myo they've tried small cells
they've tried uh um you know different
types of um uh techniques for you know
dividing up the cells Cooperative
multipoint they've experimented with
everything the whole world has come to
the the leader of the world you know the
the most advanced um um you know
Wireless operator in the world right now
the one of the largest deployment of the
most advanced technology with everything
they got and he felt he had to make a
disclosure to investors to say that they
had hit a physics limit okay and there's
lots and lots of discussion we can have
a huge debate it could take much more
than this session about whether or not
there's other things they could tweak
but there's nobody on the planet who's
going to and saying that and that the
technology as we know today can scale by
a factor of 27 by 2020 okay so if we
look at current networks already
overloaded a lot of people don't realize
that LTE is really only 3 to 4X the
capacity of 3G and 5G is at a call for
paper stage I mean people so can so I
meanc saying they can do a THX with
small cells so there are people out
there that are saying they can do much
better
so um we have one of the things that has
been overwhelming in the last two months
is the number of resumés that we've
received from people are doing actual
small cell deployments for AT&T and
Verizon and a couple other operators
around the world we've met with the
small cell people they talked about the
deployment they tried to do in the um
baggage claim area of uh SFO and what it
took to try to aim these things avoid
the small cell the interference they're
having so the problem you're run into
with small cells is this I mean uh it
looks great in theory not in practice we
ran mat lab simulations and tried to
explain to people the problem I I I use
this this is not a great explanation I'm
talking to a technical audience you
deserve a better explanation than this
this is why I say the lay people and
that is we made the cells smallers but
we did not start living cells small we
not start living in start living in doll
houses in other words the walls are just
as thick as they used to be if you put a
bunch of small cells and telephone poles
outside of buildings they need a certain
amount of power to penetrate to walls of
those buildings that amount of power in
free space goes a pretty long way okay
it's not like you've got a say a Metro
cell that is transmitting at pretty high
power and is going both a reasonable
distance that you could measure and
control and also is able to penetrate
through the sort of buildings that we
live in that's not that's not a complete
explanation there's more to it than that
and I I want to say that well in advance
but I will tell you this let's set aside
all the technology set aside everything
else look at any projection that there's
been for small cell deployment there's
nothing close to it all all the way down
the supply chain all the way to the chip
vendors who are trying to make it nobody
has deployed anything close to what they
thought was small sales yeah how much
spectrum is there available that's been
vacated by the TV
broadcasters uh is that related to small
celles or just about the capacity oh
well I mean it's nowhere near 27 times I
mean uh practical Spectrum being used
today is let's say rough numbers between
500 and uh 500 mehz and two and a half
gigahertz so that's about two G two
gigahertz of spectrum right well let's
say that everything all the way down to
HF was vacated that'd be one fif of
that'd be 500 mehz right so I I think
you know we're we're pretty much out of
spectrum okay um so you have intercell
interference okay then you have handoff
interference issues and again handoff
through you know micro these are
something called Metro cells uh is very
infrequent handoff through fto cells is
could be every second down a roadway
okay handoff a huge amount of overhead
then you get into the costs that they're
running into the zoning permits the back
hul in a cellular system if a cell fails
that that area loses coverage it's not
like the other cells can suddenly fill
in all right you lose coverage there's
public safety concerns there are no
telephone booths around for things like
uh for emergencies um so that means that
you you know they really have to look at
battery backup at the very least and
perhaps generators for all these cells
not an unreasonable proposition for a
large cell but for every every lamp
poost okay it's just practical then you
got to bring power and so forth but the
other thing you run into is is just in
terms of the layout that you need to do
so then we can go and begin to look at
um stadiums and this shows the picture
above is uh what Verizon was showing
that they did for their deployment in
the Denver bronos stadium and as you can
see they tried to go and arrange the uh
the Wi-Fi in a cellular Arrangement and
the trouble with Wi-Fi of course it's
highly variable it's subject
interference it's very difficult to
control uh this sign was up at the Super
Bowl in 2014 and they were inspecting
people with a wand to see if they had
their uh personal hotspot on uh to try
to avoid any kind of uh interference
they also were they blocked nfl.com and
they blocked all streaming videos like
getting on an airplane okay even with
all of that effort uh they had 800%
growth in uh usage of WiFi from uh the
previous Super Bowl and some of the
fascinating statistics are 18% their
traffic were iPhones updating themselves
in people's
pockets so they just so the the amount
of stuff that you run into these days in
terms of the capacity is just
overwhelming and even look at that
picture of course by the people on the
edges of those little cells they've
created have terrible service the people
in the center might get good service and
so forth so you just got a very highly
variable situation mindful of time here
okay so let's talk about Pell all right
um let me run a video which is on our
website but nonetheless we'll give you
kind of an overview and then I'll go
into a lot more detail about
it
smartphones tablets and laptops they're
just the beginning of an era where smart
internet enabled devices of all kinds
demand more and more mobile data at
reliably fast
speeds we've added cells improved
networks increased Spectrum but the the
truth is our always on connected world
is running out of capacity with demand
for data projected to increase
dramatically by 20120 the time has come
for new
thinking the time has come for Pell
technology pel is an entirely new
approach to wireless designed to
profoundly increase the data capacity of
our finite Spectrum in an existing
cellular network each Tower transmits a
radio signal forming a large cell and
carefully avoiding interference with
other cells mobile devices all share the
cell's capacity taking turns so they
don't interfere with each other this all
worked great until everybody started
carrying smartphones and tablets
streaming photos music and videos even
with more spectrum and small cells
demand is far outpacing capacity and
we've hit a physics upper
limit P cell technology turns the whole
problem inside out instead of dodging
interference Pell exploits interference
combining radio signals to synthesize
tiny personal cells P cells of wireless
energy around each mobile device so
rather than hundreds of users taking
turns sharing the capacity of one large
cell each user gets an unshared P cell
giving the full Wireless capacity to
each user at once it's nothing short of
a revolution in Wireless even in the
biggest crowds there is a P cell for
every user device and no matter no
matter where you go you've got a fast
lag-free mobile connection simple
discret p-wave radios can be placed
anywhere it is convenient making cell
towers a thing of the past Pell
technology realizes the dream of
ubiquitous Broadband connectivity it
changes the game making it possible for
thousands of fans to share video
instantly delivering reliable video
conferencing whether closing a deal on
Wall
Street showing your family the the
lights of Time
Square or smoothly streaming an HD movie
for a 3-hour
drive with Pell technology Wireless is
fast reliable always there Pell
technology from
emis all
right so let me talk about what those
things are and how they work
and um let's
see oh good good on that thing and then
oh okay so uh in an idealized cellular
network you have an arrangement like
this looks like a um honeycomb
Arrangement where you have the base
stations in the center and they're all
ideally spaced and then what you end up
in the real world is something more like
what we have in the center picture here
where you just can't place things in
ideal positions there's obstacles and so
forth you might ends up with a dead zone
and even though you do a really thorough
job in planning your cellular system if
you had increased the the size of any of
those cells nearby you would interfere
with other ones
um you have some cells that are are you
know inter are someone has a fto cell in
the middle of a macro cell their
apartment's working great their neighbor
is screaming bloody murder because
nothing works for them right so it
really depends Pell it's a very
different approach what we say is let's
go place the base stations anywhere they
can really be deployed randomly they're
deployed based on where the economics
make it least expensive and convenient
to deploy them and they can have um they
vary in their power level in fact they
vary by millisecond in fact power which
is not a dimension you have much control
over in a cellular system you know like
inter cell varies slightly to increase
or make the cell smaller in their sewn
technology we vary the power enormously
um throughout the use of our system so
some of those coverage areas are bigger
some are smaller it doesn't matter how
they over what they cover whereas this
is largely an if then technology this is
very much a mathematics technology okay
we don't do any if then we don't have
time for it frankly with the what what
we're doing if you then add users into
uh into both cellular and Pell Worlds
the users of the red dots as you can see
there's an unfortunate user in The Dead
Zone there you have some people that are
near cell center and they're very happy
because they've good performance there
there's some near the cell Edge which
not so great you have that neighbor of
the person who has the fto cell in their
apartment who's uh has great coverage
from a small cell and a macro cell and
they're screaming bloody murder because
neither of them of course allows them to
receive a phone call um then with with P
cell then you notice with if I go back
the coverage for cell uh for cellular
and the signal quality for cellular the
same thing with P cell the coverage and
the signal quality are completely
different right what happens is we have
these overlapping signals and the
overlapping signals sum together it's
quite different than a myo type of
structure where it's a base station
based system where the the number of um
Transmissions from the antennas um is uh
directly is is directly tied to the
number of users these antennas um have a
varying number of users that each of
them are serving some overlapping some
not it's a user Centric wirel system
it's a different approach and unlike myo
it's not cubic as it grows it is linear
and unlike myo does not need to be
cellularized or clustered rather it's a
it's a pure coverage area just
distributed well uh we haven't seen any
distributed M that goes to scale time
he's getting
results con the project was part of it
playback distribute sense networks was
only there some of the participants
there well it' be great we'd love to see
the paper because we have for the
reports they're not all available they
are ask Bob Khan for what is available
from B Dara all right well I think I've
done my talk then maybe Bob can give the
talk
okay U we I just want to give you a
little bit history M re here well all
right so every time I give a talk we
always have people we have two things
one thing is if I give a talk and I'm
not giving a demo when I show the demos
they say that it's in a it's in a
controlled environment I invite them to
come we have yet to have one person take
us up the only people are taking us up
on on the demos are all the carriers um
and they're the ones who want this so uh
really badly the other thing we hear is
this has all been done before and I have
to tell you we've reached a point after
two months of people saying it can't be
done we show it does work and then they
go then literally the same meeting they
said this paper
we we just want to see the published
paper if you could point us all the
paper both myself everybody's listening
we'd love to see the published paper
love to see the results I would imagine
anybody who's receiving who's achieving
the results that we're achieving would
have published and I think the world
would have noticed but I could be
mistaken if there's something else out
there we'd love to learn from it okay uh
we certainly do not view ourselves as as
have inventing you know everything there
is in Wireless we're we're built upon
the shoulders of giants right and if
they did this something before and
there's something to be learned from it
that's they forgot to tell the world
that they had solved the capacity
problem we'd love to know about it
creating a cenim cell with a small
number of that are distributed we didn't
we don't know the full answer to that I
have a friend who's a physicist and I
told him about this he says you're not
doing that I said we are and we could
show him the cell because we could we
everyone stands still in the room we
turn off the adaptation so it doesn't um
you know so uh it doesn't change it it
it uses the last Channel State
information it had okay
and when you move it you can see the
cell edges are around a few millimeters
away from the center you can actually
see the edges okay it's a really cool
demo and his because you know he's been
doing work at CERN and things like that
he has a whole different view of the
world than we do you know what I mean
and we were thinking it probably be more
in the order of a wavelength a half
wavelength something like that it's more
like a tenth of a wavelength so we have
a theory and this is where we really
want to embrace Academia Academia bring
them in show them what it is and get
over all these questions about you know
we it doesn't really matter who invented
what right we just want it to be known
and out there you know what I mean the
um we'd like to have we I think that the
one of the reasons that it may be is
that what you have is these
intersecting um waves coming in at all
different angles and what you're getting
is all these slices together and
essentially the place where there's
coherence amongst all of them when you
have all these different angles and and
even different polarizations these
different angles ends up to be a small
fraction of wavelength okay okay that's
the best theory we have right now we're
not physicists you know what I'm saying
we we come from the World of Wireless
but you're doing some kind of adaptation
so that must be based on optimizing
something it is an adaptation but it's a
based on the adaptation of of a
measurement from um each of these points
here based on the Uplink I mean
basically we just take um the standard
uplink from LT devices we don't do
anything anything different or in the
case of Wi-Fi just a standard up link of
Wi-Fi devices and with that I mean the
other thing about Pell I think that
people don't realize is that there's a
whole series of inventions that that
came out of this you know if you go look
back to the basic concept in di it's not
nearly sufficient to explain what we
have here okay and so one of the things
we had to do for example is uh deal with
uh completely uncalibrated RF chains on
the Uplink and on the down link oh thank
you Cindy and the um um and so we we
have a system which is incredibly
elegant now because we take the
uncalibrated RF you know the signal
coming from all these different devices
to a completely you know different
transm you know uncalibrated downlink
Etc and we're able you know within
microseconds to be able to go and and
make a decision about the channel State
information and we get a lot of
information in fact we're collecting
more information than is currently than
is needed for myo or is used by myo okay
um and that is affecting our decision
about what we do for example allows us
to create a mesh here that's why I I'd
love to if they figure out a way to do
this like say a my thousand array of
antennas completely linearly I need to
know about that because we have that was
a we have a uh we we invented a way to
solve that obviously but it was a very
very difficult problem um and it it
requires a series of practical
considerations about the realities of a
wireless deployment as well as um uh
some terrific work on the math and you
know and the layering of the matrices
when you say linearly is that referring
to complexity or yeah computational
complexity so in other words as you you
add each the computational complexity of
P cell grows with the number of Base
stations or the number of radio heads
really is what they are we call them p
waves all right so in a MMO system that
would grow with a cube of the number of
uh Square what was that n log
Square okay more precisely okay um and
so in our case as I said we we work
really really hard to make that linear
so if somebody else has got that and we
can go leverage that work we'd love to
um and the other thing about it is you
because of that you and the other thing
you have of course is you know if you're
doing deployment across the city of San
Francisco obviously the antennas on the
far end of the city are not going to be
able to affect the users on on the other
end of the city and vice versa right so
in it you know the way we that's handled
today is the world's broken into cells
or clusters of some sort you know
whether you're doing whether it's
cellular cognitive radio Wi-Fi whatever
it is you know it ends somewhere it
begins somewhere else Etc we don't we
have a complete uh we have a complete
blanket across the entire city and if a
user goes there with a P cell they
continue across the city and it's
seamless and and we're doing that again
as a completely linear function of the
number of p-wave antennas that was years
of work to make that happen right so as
I said if there's a general solution
which get thousand by thousand Matrix
and in a completely um linear way go and
uh achieve some of the things we're
doing we would certainly like to
consider that all right but anyways
what's that is it possible for the P
cells to operate peer-to-peer
uh
no um uh this is not that's it's a um
this is a cran architecture and uh it is
important for us to have a central
control for for everything it is the
case though that as I said the it's a
system which has one one data center
it's one cran for an entire metro area
there are no cells there are no clusters
okay it's a user Center system it's
mobile here's another thing for example
it's not sensitive to Doppler okay and
so it's another thing very different
than myo so again if this technology is
not sense of doopler that'd be great to
know but you know I'm going to spend the
whole talk on lot slide
one is that essential um tdd works
better there less overhead um we have we
we have a lot more flexibility with
Channel State information than has been
available before this calibration
technology we've developed turns out it
solves a bunch of other problems as well
but a tdd system is nice because we
don't there's a certain amount we have
to get a certain amount of information
from the up down Link channel that's not
available in the Uplink Channel we don't
need necessarily perfect information but
we do need some um in the tdd system the
Uplink is simple I mean the Uplink gives
us everything we need for both uh P cell
going uh obviously Downstream and P cell
going Upstream okay so we'd prefer that
um there's another weird thing about
Pell and this will really mess your
minds up okay it works in
existing um it works simultaneously in
existing cellular Spectrum without
interfering with the existing cellular
deployment okay even if you have a
completely saturated system for example
uh take San Francisco where I just
mentioned the down link is completely
saturated the up link is uh is only
partially loose and so forth we can
deploy P cell over we can overlay P cell
over that and that would be an FDD
overlay okay uh and we can go and then
grow the capacity from there without
inter in with the current use of the
spectrum even if it's currently
saturated for Cellular use it's a very
very different yeah how do you weed the
meses together I vote that we allow you
to give your talk instead of
interrupting you all the time okay let
let me get through this thing and then
I'll answer and I can and again we want
to have this not be the end of a
dialogue perhaps the beginning um one
other practical consideration is when
you're going to add a lot of different
um uh radio heads how do you go and and
do the back haul for them when I started
this project I actually went up to
Seattle and met with Craig mcau and I
said I really before I spend a lot of
time on this thing I want to understand
one of the real economics of cellular he
says everyone thinks it's the radios
that are expensive it isn't it's the
back haul and the real estate okay so in
a cellular system you largely need fiber
back haul just because you have to
choose the locations have to be spread
out in some sort of a cellular plan
you're never going to get an ideal plan
but you do the best you can sometimes
you can do line of sight Lin of sight
after you paid for the linos sight Radio
is free for example you use 24 GHz or 70
or even 60 for shorter runs um but it's
makes it very expensive so with Pell
what we did is we make it so you can
place the radio heads wherever you'd
like and so what you do you choose the
locations which are economically most
efficient for example in San Francisco
we have a partner that has done a w a
line ofite uh Wireless deployment where
they they deliver through Ethernet
through the um uh telephone closets to
um to you know apartment buildings and
businesses uh service that is back
hauled through their linos sight U mesh
the criteria for choosing a building is
the landlord will let them use the
rooftop for free and it's got line of
sight to another one of their buildings
okay and they've been building this up
for about 10 years and they've got 350
rooftops 5 milliseconds worst case
latency and they're usually getting
about half of the um customers in each
building to drop Comcast or or DSL but
of course you know the buildings if you
we we've run simulations if you try to
go and build a cellular network on top
of those buildings it it's very very
poor performance cuz the buildings some
of them are right next to each other
some are very far apart etc for pel
though that works just fine their entire
network is served by six fiber drops so
they have covered the entire city of San
Francisco with only six fiber
connections all the rest of it is free
um so this shows also in a stadium the
advantages that we get with uh P cell
and uh as you can see this is the
traditional kind of cellular approach
whether it's cellular by doing it with
LT or with Wi-Fi with Pell of course you
have a little small little cell around
each phone and uh you can expand any
density you'd like okay so let me show
you a couple videos here um this a video
we haven't shown before so it's kind of
cool we had a lot of questions about
Doppler so this one kind of shows off
the Doppler thing
um let's
see full screen
here and off we
go
hi I'm Steve proman founder and CEO of
Artemis networks and we're here for
another edition of our lab demo series
now what we're going to be showing you
here are 16 LT devices iPhone 5c 5s and
Google Nexus 5S all simultaneously
sharing 10 MHz of spectrum all streaming
HD video simultaneously but with only
eight p-wave radios now previously we
showed you an iPhone running uh eight
iPhones running in 5 MHz of spectrum all
streaming HD with eight p-wave radios
and a lot of people asked us hey do you
need as many p-wave radios as you have
devices well now because we're in 10 MHz
of spectrum these devices do not need
all 10 MHz and so they're able to share
the Spectrum and the P cell technology
was designed so that even with a much
smaller number of uh p-wave radios than
we have LT devices we nonetheless can
still synthesize an individual P cell
for each of these devices and as you can
see we're running YouTube Vimeo and
Netflix on these different devices and
they're all very happily working
together all right so another question
that has been asked before is what
happens when you have a uh an LT radio
um using P cell when it's in motion
right now the technical term in the
wireless world for uh motion sensitivity
is Doppler sensitivity all right now
other uh Wireless Technologies which
utilize the spatial characteristics of
of wireless radio waves is that um when
you have things rapidly in motion they
are unable to work they can only really
work when things are are hardly moving
at all or moving very slowly so in this
case we do not have sensitivity to
Doppler with P cell technology and the
reason we don't is that we're exploiting
characteristics of a distributed antenna
system which are not possible to exploit
when all your antennas are located in
one location or perhaps in just three
locations for example with myo or
cooperative multipoint so to illustrate
this of course people know that with you
know YouTube Vimeo uh Netflix any video
technology it buffers the video so maybe
when I'm moving it the video is already
buffered right to illustrate that that's
not the case what I'm going to do is
Advance the buffer way past to where I
am and then I'm going to move the phone
as you see the video starts right up as
it loads the buffer just as it would if
it was not in motion and there you go
the video is running all right right in
fact I'm going to show you something
it's going to be hard to watch on camera
I'm going to advance the video and then
really shake this
thing and I'm going to move it around
and so on and it when I stop you'll see
the video is happily working so even
with that kind of Rapid motion and with
all 16 of these devices running at once
as you can see Pell technology is
insensitive to Doppler all right so
thank you very much for joining us again
for one of our lab demo series and uh
hope to have some new stuff for you soon
he said when it stops started working so
it wasn't working while you were moving
it no you couldn't see no it was working
moving it do I you couldn't see it you
know the people who are viewing this I
don't know if they can they can go frame
by frame and maybe even see it and
they'll see that actually the video if
if you what you know you trying to make
these things concise for YouTube
otherwise people give up on them but um
what I should have done probably is say
here's the normal buffering process when
you advance the video it Tes it goes It
goes it shows a couple of still frames
and then it plays and if you watch the
slow one I was hoping you could see that
and the fast one the same thing it never
goes and buffers and then lets go the
video I mean either way for it to start
the video when I stopped moving it had
to have buffered it you know what I'm
saying but it was playing the video
while I was doing it it's kind of hard
to see that's why I said when you're
moving very fast but again the best
thing to do is come to the lab we have
nothing to hide you know what I mean
it's um but clearly if this like
Cooperative multipoint myo I think it's
well known that if you have things fast
motion you can't use them because the
channel stay information you collect is
um you know is obsolete by the time you
actually uh try to go and turn around
and form your signals you know um to
synthesize your signals so again um how
long do I have till 5:30 5:30 all right
I I'll show you one more video which is
one that has been up there but
nonetheless it just shows uh the
capacity we have it's a little less
Technical and that's on this here um and
I'll try to maybe fast forward to the
good parts um let's
see so here I'll introduce what it is
and then I'll just kind of zip ahead
because it takes a little while to get
the video started if you want to watch
the whole thing it's on
YouTube hi I'm Steve prman founder and
CEO of
emis so we're going to show you right
now is the technology behind Pell and
we're going to show you that by using
actual lab radios instead of using you
know a LTE radio that's a commercial
product the reason we're going to do
that is it allows us to go and show you
the actual signal that's going through
and also allows us to turn off certain
things built into LT like for example
error correction so if there are any
imperfections you'll see them because we
want to show you them all right and you
can see that each of these PCS back here
and these are Tablet PCs we're running
Linux on all of them and then on the
back of them is a lab radio that allows
us to go and um be exactly like an LTE
receiver with the difference being that
of course as I mentioned we're able to
turn off the features that would
normally make it a cleaner signal and
and also allow to you to see what's
going on all right so first of all
what's happening now is we don't have P
cell technology turned on all the p
waves that we have in the room are
transmitting the same signal just as if
they were in a conventional cellular
system so what do we see here every
device has the exact same video playing
because that's what happens when
everyone's transmitting in the same
Spectrum the same signal so you can see
we got six different videos playing the
other thing I want to point out is this
little white box here that's called a
constellation now constellation is what
is used by radios in order to go and
take the waves coming in the phase
shifts and the amplitude changes then
map them into a graph this is something
called a for quam or qpsk it's the
simplest form of it when those little
dots are all happily in their little
quadrants in their Corners that means
you've got a good signal if they get all
scattered about and you see noise that
means you don't have a signal all right
so as you can see all of them are very
happily receiving their nice cute psk
signal in their constellation and
they're all displaying HDTV all right so
now what we're going to do is flip on
the P cell technology and watch closely
CU now each of them is going to get
their own private P cell around their
antenna and each of them then is going
to receive a different video so let's
flip on P cell
technology and there you are all of them
are still getting their for quam signal
their Q psk signal and their
constellation the reason they're a
little bit noisy if this is lab radio
equipment it's supposed to commercial
equipment that's why you see a little
bumpiness the normal signal you see is
actually quite clean and then the other
thing you can see is that if I pick one
of these guys
up yeah the signal keeps on going all
right you see it it it adapts the Little
P cell that's around here is following
the radio as I move it around now notice
what happens if I put the antennas right
next to each other so I got this guy and
this guy connected okay no problem you
can have the antennas that close and
they're still independent let's suppose
I get three antennas close to each other
all right so I got antenna back here
antenna back there three devices that
close together the P cell technology is
so specific into as to where it actually
delivers the P cell that you can have
devices that close without them
interfering all right so now I'm going
to show you something that's actually
really magical and that is a chance to
actually go and see a P cell in space
but you're going to have to work with me
on it all right so let me show you how
we can demonstrate it now obviously the
radio waves are invisible all right so
the best I can do to show you where a P
cell is is kind of to go map out where
it is and where it isn't so normally as
I move it around you see how the
constellation stays together and the
video plays no problem all right I'm
going to turn off that feature of the P
cell system which is what we call the
adaptation all right which will move
around the P cell as we move around the
device now and I have to hold it very
steady and if I hold it steady the video
will play but as soon as I move it even
the slightest amount you'll see it will
move out of the C Pell and back in all
right so let's turn off the
adaptation so everything plays fine now
watch How I move this guy just a little
bit see constellation breaks up video
stops move back video plays again move a
little bit to the side constellation
breaks up video stops and move it back
in there's the video again move it down
move back up there's the video again
move move it up there's the B you again
move it towards
you and it breaks up move back down move
it away from you video breaks up moves
it back down so there you have it so
literally what I just mapped out going
forward backwards up down left and right
is the shape of the P cell it's about a
centimeter okay so let's turn on
adaptation again now watch as I move it
around it follows all right so that's
the magic of what we've created here
we've created indiv idual cells which
follow you all right so um I I didn't
quite know where to break thats too when
that when you move your tablet one of
the PCS started breaking up too because
we CH if we've done demos of that the
other demo we did that again be too
short is I just hold it steady and one
person like takes a step forward it
changes the channel state of the whole
environment um and so by moving the
tablet I wasn't just I was channeling
changing the channel it depends where
the waves are I mean you could have
someone walk right here and nothing
changes or you have someone lift a
finger and all of them go nuts it just
it depends on the multipath in the room
right so um it's it's interesting I it's
an area of study that I think is going
to be a lot of fun um but let me go and
get back into the presentation here so
um and we'll go
here all right so we showed the demo
okay so um so this this is one of the
things about cellular that just inherent
in the way this is from Ericson this is
their they U had a little uh report they
did last year and people don't really
think don't realize that well cellular
was a really really good solution for
telepan because you'd have you end up
with this low data rate on the edge
cellular only works well for data near
the cell centers that's true whether
it's a a macro cell micro cell or a
small cell CU in order for cellular to
work it has to taper off performance so
the average performance of a cell is
about one tenth that of what the cell
the Peak Performance is and of course as
Ericson points out by the time you get
to the middle of a cell it's very
difficult to do much more than music or
the web and by the time you get to the
edge of the cell it's very difficult to
do much more than uh tany you know voice
and uh things like Twitter um and um uh
telepan messaging and things like
Twitter whereas Pell What's significant
is that you you're creating these cell
centers all over the place and we're
getting Peak Performance throughout the
coverage area so even in a small cell
situation suppose suppose that small
cells didn't have interference issues
and didn't have inell interference and
didn't have um handoff issues it's still
the case this is a vastly more efficient
way of deploying Wireless when we put P
cell radio heads at the exact same
location as uh cellular antennas in a
cellular system we right there get a 10x
increase in the average performance but
most importantly beond on the overall
capacity increase what we do is create a
very very consistent throughput all
right so you can see this um in terms of
this simulation that we did um we were
showing this before um my previous talk
I gave but anyways this shows a ideal
cellular layout it distributes um phones
throughout the area and then we' run the
mat lab simulation there's these
characteristic volcanoes as we call them
where you have very high Sr and then it
it has to go and taper off towards the
edge so we actually we gave cellular the
benefit of Doubt here this is like in
Kansas as if it was an outer space I
mean so there's no shadowing you know
it's just just simple showing it U
because we want to show a nice clean
signal here um and then as you can see
you know user number one happens to be
right near the cell center they're
getting terrific performance user number
two is between two cells and so well too
bad for you um and then everything in
between and again if you average it out
across the area you find out you're
getting about one tenth the performance
of the peak of say what user one or six
is getting if you now for Pell we're
using the real 3gpp shadowy and path
loss model here because we want to be
you know be as as bad Cas as we we can
be and we've actually find that it
models what we it's a pretty good model
to use to for the uh outdoor work that
we've been doing and anyways the uh and
and the inor work but it anyways it it
has all the shadowing and all the other
issues which is why it's a little bit
more noisy but anyway um as you see with
the exact same antenna layout the exact
same user device positioned we're
getting a Peak each of the user devices
and so you get this very uniform
performance throughout the coverage area
and that's the 10x increase if we go and
cluster the
users you see you get the this problem
where not only do you get highly
variable throughput depending on where
they are on the volcano but of course
they're all sharing the same capacity in
the case of Pell almost all the devices
are getting uh Peak Performance and um
as you can see the reason this is
possible is of course they're getting
the benefit from the farway antennas uh
these guys here are only getting the
benefit from this antenna these other
antennas can't help them at all and
we've seen this is not just an issue of
people being able to watch videos where
they want to this is a public safety
issue uh when the um the bomb exploded
in um um during the Boston Marathon
about a year ago uh the AP reported that
all the cellular networks were told to
shut down their service to avoid using
cellular to detonate another bomb two
hours later they retracted that report
saying it was a rumor okay what happened
was that of course you have one cell
covering that area for every one of
those uh carriers all the four carriers
carriers and every one of them people
were pulling out their phone saying I'm
either okay I need help or people trying
to call in and so forth it jammed the
service there are no more payones okay
so they had they created a dead zone you
know utterly unusable Zone you know in
every you know 4G 3G and so on every
class of service was overwhelmed and um
that's that's a significant issue with
Pell if something like that happened
where we had a sudden U burst of of
activity I mean I guess if you looked at
you'd see that the power would rise up
on the further away antennas but of
course much more complex stuff would go
on and You' be able to serve users even
if they're clustered very close together
um yeah is that the same cell density
and the same Transit power per cell in
same maximum Transit power um and that
is actually I'm not I don't know I think
that the transit power can be higher in
this case I'll have to check I don't
remember to be honest because
the thing that we're getting we do we do
need less power than you'd think and the
reason is because of um uh maximum ratio
combining and and and things like that
we're getting a we're getting a benefit
from a summation of these different
antennas whether that benefit is enough
for this guy to reach all the way to
there I don't remember and Antonio did
the simulation that's a good question to
ask him um but the thing about it with
cellular is that there's times when you
want to transmit with more power but you
can't okay and um but the the
simulations if we get to it um that I
have we do match power for power we have
the same and I can show you what it's
like a cellular system versus A P cell
system with the exact same antenna
locations I'm not sure if this one is
that okay this one we were just trying
to show what you could do in kind of a
real deployment and kind of illustrate
the bumpiness of cellular and and versus
the uniformity because it's not just all
about capacity now it's it's also about
if you want to deliver media you need
uniformity clarify you said you're using
Maxim ratio combining how is how was
that used here
um it is
used use both well okay so we have these
antennas
here and this is where you're this is
where you're crossing the bridge between
my perhaps not my depth of knowledge of
wireless and Antonio's I'm I'm a little
more of a conceptual thinker so if I've
used the termine correctly I'm apologize
to everyone I think I I think I've used
it correctly though um we have each of
these guys is receiving a signal from
all these different antennas uh some of
the signals they receive could
theoretically be below the noise floor
and the summation of the signals add up
to something more on the Uplink for
example I do know because that's
actually one of the big features of the
system is that on the Uplink the receive
signal from all these different antennas
um the receive signal from say user 2 on
I don't know on this antenna maybe too
low for it to really res you know
receive much and it is able to go and
and go and utilize the data together
that utilize the signals together and
combine them and from that is able to
get uh a um get a highed you know a
higher data rate while uh operating at a
much lower transmit power so that's what
the P cell is doing is the
comb
uh so I think that the correct answer to
that question the exact answer to that
question um we better answered by
Antonio I wish I brought him um but
actually maybe Sydney you can call him
we can give you the answer before the
talk is over all right he can just join
dead zone right here oh I'm in a dead
zone can you ask him whether or
not I so um there are when I my there
there's a variety of techniques that can
be used to statistically combine the
signals I do know this that when we're
doing the Uplink the receive signal here
to a given one of our radio heads can be
below the noise floor yet the aggregate
of the signals can allow us to resolve
the signal you mean for the P because
that's the Wi-Fi right so it no this is
cell cellular and Wi-Fi it works the
same way so right so the maxim ratio
combining is part of what your P cell
Technologies
do um if that is the right name for
taking signal to multiple antennas that
are distributed and combine the signals
together so that the the the aggreg the
statistical aggregation of the signals
goes and results in a um a higher power
signal or or a better SI INR signal I
should better done on the Uplink on all
of those it's on the Uplink and I think
what we're doing on the down link we are
getting the benefit from the aggregation
of the antennas I can believe that
whether there but there's more than one
technique that I think can be used for
that I don't know if M uh MRC is exactly
the
technique that one allow me to isolate
the users in their own little cell if
you're using the antenna just for
combining oh no no no no that's not I so
I think your question was are we using
MRC in order to go and create the P cell
technology and the answer is no you said
yes no I said we're using that to go and
allow us to go and allow an LT phone's
battery to last longer so if you have a
an iPhone it might last two days or
three days um in a Pell Network rather
than in a cellular network because in a
cellular network if you're very far if
you're on the edge of the cell and you
spend the whole day talking on the phone
your thing's transmitting and you know
some people wonder why does your phone
burn down some days and other days it
lasts forever right okay so with
Pell if you got this whether you're on
the down link or the Uplink you have
very high sinr so the phone the power
requirements are very low the demos we
just showed you are at 1 mwatt right
even indoors one mwatt is not a lot
okay okay well either way it's
sufficient for our demos okay I don't I
don't um but as I
said talk only one only one question per
slide we move CL this slide okay so um
this goes and shows um serendipitous
deployment that is to say where the
antennas are spread about where it's the
least expensive we gave the benefit of
down for cellular to make the users kind
of randomly scattered of course in this
case here the cellular the question
about power um comes into play here this
cell can't increase its power you'd like
it to be able to because it would run
into that cell cuz they're they're too
close together this guy again each of
them is bounded on some Edge so you end
up with extremely low performance even
if you have the users completely spread
out across the coverage area with Pell
it really doesn't matter where the
antennas are located you're still
creating a peak of sinr wherever the
users are located all right and um okay
so the other thing we did is just make
it compatible with LT and Wi-Fi devices
we can work in licensed or unlicensed
Spectrum um and for example Wi-Fi
obviously is on licensed Spectrum we
could do um um uh a carrier can
gradually do P cell deployments and then
we do a handoff on the edge of the P
cell coverage area to Cellular or they
could do a whole large region if they'd
like to um in the US what the
conversations are largely about P cell
deployment and then handing off to LTE
on the edge it's interesting in other
countries um particularly we're seeing
in Southeast Asia um there is a huge
interest in not ever deploying LTE or
they've done a little bit in their
cities but the idea they would have they
want to deploy Pell it's much less
expensive from a c uh Capital Equipment
cost capex and also from an operating
cost they can build devices that are
Pell only that do not have the all the
stack that you need for a cellular
system and so they're much less
expensive and then they would build
phones which would hand off to 3G they
already have 3G maybe 2G networks Etc so
um this so it's interesting I again one
of the unexpected results after our
announcement is that people are thinking
about skipping LTE altogether um in
entire very very large Nations um so you
can do things with MV Ando um I mean
it's public knowledge that we've done an
FCC filing with Dish I can just can't
disclose anything about the relationship
but I think it's obvious to everyone
that they have lots of spectrum they
have 50 mehz of spectrum but they have
no infrastructure so for operators like
that okay obviously this is a very less
a much less expensive op much lower cost
option and they can begin to deploy it
because we're compa with LT devices they
can begin to deploy it in major uh uh
say met major metros other places they
High congestion and then use mvn to hand
off uh you know to another operator
until they finish their
deployment okay so um this shows the CR
architecture it's very conceptual it's a
completely sof defined radio system um
the fact that it runs in real time the
demos you've seen we've been running on
you know uh two um dual 8 core Intel
machines they're running Linux um and um
we're using National instruments usurps
from uh what's the
answer te
that's the answer but the cells are
transmitting the average power is the
same but the further away cells transmit
higher and the closer cells transmit
lower and then the other question I just
okay so it so was it the other question
what the other question I I couldn't I
could okay so the answer in that mat
laap simulation you saw the further
cells are transing at higher power uh
okay in the um in the P cell version
okay so the uh it's it's a full software
uh defined radio implementation I do not
think we could have designed this if we
were not using software defined radio
the iterations we do per day are just
amazing it's been it's been a revelation
for me um of just seeing what we can do
and a lot of it was very fundamental
work on doing uh the low-level code
particularly in the physical layer uh to
make it all Run in real time this shows
a diagram of what you might do this
would be like the cran we call it dran
for a one of a better word the data
center uh and you know we typically have
been doing deployments we do our testing
we put eight antennas on a rooftop you
know most it depends how big the roof is
obviously but that seems to be pretty
good spacing for getting it going um and
so you can imagine I me 10 gbits fiber
going you could have fiber to a rooftop
or say 10 gaug to a rooftop then line a
sight through some mesh like this okay
um in um if we're talking about tdd in
uh 20 MHz we get uh about 70 megabits
per second of down link and um each P
wave radio or each radio head um adds
the adds 70 megabits per second to the
aggregate capacity of the coverage area
so if you have 10 of them you'll have
700 megabits per second if you 100 you
know you have um 7 gbits and so on um
and then that aggre capacity is shared
by all the user devices each device
obviously is limited by the Shannon
limit you know so it can only receive to
each antenna uh 70 megabits per second
if it's a two antenna device you receive
140 and so on um the um and you can then
divide up the capacity any way you'd
like I mean some users can be getting
all everyone can be getting 10 you can
five and so forth but the thing about
this that's very significant that's very
different cellular is that when I say
that each of these P p-wave radio heads
adds you know in this case 70 megabits
per second of capacity it's not 70
megabits Peak that's pretty much 70
megabits average there are some factors
that make it slightly below average it's
not perfect you saw the mat lab
culations there's a lot of details but
it's it's way closer to Peak that it is
to uh anything else so it's a very
efficient way of deploying uh um
um so deploying a radio system a
question getting kind of impatient with
not hearing what he wants to tell us
yeah well this is an academic seminar
which means there typically our
questions okay so um my question is how
are you um isolating each one of those
devices can you uh in in terms of
getting this spatially isolated P it's
entirely based on the Uplink in the case
of the uplink from LTE it has some you
know very convenient waveforms there's
SRS there's uh is it uh cmrs I forget
what the other one's called there's a
couple things it does which are nice
because they're orthogonal to each other
and so forth and they're just they're
designed for this very purpose but
they're just not calibrated they're
mainly meant for kind of rough beam
forming okay but because of this
technology we invented we are able to
use them to get a absolute precise I
mean 16 bits of resolution precise
Channel State information as if we're
right there but uh uh using reciprocity
it's very exciting okay then you be
formed to the each individual we don't
be form we create uh um I mean not beam
form either in the AR Raycom view of the
world where you kind of you know aiming
beams you know like in a phas array
antenna I'm not giving them Justice
they've done a lot of work beyond that
it's a phas array it's it's not a phas
array um and it is rather rather a um um
a complex combination of of these
different antennas as I said there is no
single group of antennas that serves one
group of users for example I'm a user
here and I've got a group each each has
got a group of antennas the group of
antennas are actually interleaved
amongst each other okay and so this
antenna here might be serving this user
and that user whereas this antenna here
is only serving that user this antenna
is only serving that user all right and
uh I don't know a big truck comes by and
now this antenna for one millisecond is
not serving this user and then the truck
goes away and then it is okay it adapts
at that that that level of resolution in
fact when we do P cell native where we
able to go and and do a protocol that's
not limited to the LT frame structure we
can do it on on uh you know microsc
basis so isn't that distributed line I
mean I know someone else has that but
that what distri does you have a whole
bunch of antennas and they're figuring
out the optimal use of the antennas to
serve multiple users so the distributed
M systems that we've done we looked at
some of the work done I think at USC um
is that uh it's been done all over the
world I mean it's actually yeah okay so
we keep we've looked at all those papers
um we've uh seen the different things we
haven't seen anyone has been able to
achieve um this capacity this level of
uh
linearity um been able to overcome the
uh lots of other challenges near far and
so forth I mean um again um
I you can you can go and visit him he's
in pal Alto we're in San Francisco now
we're doing City tests but please all of
you everyone in this room you know I
would love to organize a field trip come
here ask all the questions we got so
many whiteboards you know uh we got also
we have the you know the phds there who
when it comes to the very very deep
questions you're asking can answer them
better than I do I'm more of a
conceptual generalist you know what I
mean um and I am uh uh but let me let me
just get through a couple things because
this is more of a computer sciency thing
that
I really like and I think that um it's a
new thing for for Wireless in a way um
so the way this this shows actually
what's happening inside the system we
have virtualized wireless um if you see
here's the user devices and you can see
the P cell around them the P cell's
really around the antenna but I think
you know what I'm talking about here
they're all in each case they have an
individual Channel okay in this case we
have eight user devices and in that case
we actually have what we call virtual
radio instances so in software we've
implemented in this case eight EOD BS
EOD BS you might or may or may not know
is the name for the stack that is in the
center of Al cell okay and so we have
then these p waves distributed and as I
was saying before these guys go and
Uplink their signal all these guys hear
that signal and remember they're
scattered about and uh they all receive
that signal we do um we pass back the
information to the the data center and
then simultaneously what's happening is
these eobs each are going and creating a
completely separate LTE signal if you
would take an anten take this signal
here digitized um you know have an ad D
to a and put an antenna out here you
know the phone in your pocket would try
to connect to it okay so we have eight
simultaneous LT signals that are being
created digitally here they feed into
here and then what we do through this
processing is we go and do a mapping a
spatial mapping between one of these Zod
BS and a device for example examp Le um
VRI
3 appears at the receiving point of the
antenna of uh user device 3 um and you
know V6 appears right here okay and
literally if you take a piece of LT you
know test equipment that's what it shows
then it will actually show that H I'm
all alone here there's no one else using
uh any of the resource blocks and I have
the full channel to myself okay now
um new system like um that's on the next
slide I love it when people ask a
question say here's the next
slide so you obviously uh not every like
take take 70 megabits per second LT was
sized LT bandwidth everything was sized
for many many users sharing one uh eode
B so clearly what we're doing is I mean
unless someone's got a ridiculously high
data rate application um for mobile
applications we're way over delivering
in terms of capacity right so we can go
and divide up the the that capacity
using either um ofdma or
tdma and in this case it shows ofdma and
um here we've we've decided okay none of
these users needs more than half the
throughput of the channel so let's go
put half of them on the lower band and
half of them on the upper band okay and
so here you have um the green users
obviously in the upper band and lower
band and the system is able to assign so
with four p-wave antennas here we are
serving eight users simple enough you be
you have to preserve certain ratio right
as the number of users as the density
increases in a certain area you'll need
to put more and more P antennas in that
area no it's it's it's related to the
data demand in the area the data rate
well assuming each one just continues to
keep the same data demand and you have
to kind of go and put more and more of
your antennas in that if it's the case
you really but think about it I mean you
know we're talking about increasing just
by deploying these p-wave antennas at
the same location as current cellular
antennas an operator gets a 10x increase
in capacity so it takes a while to fill
that well and then yes if you want to go
beyond that you can start adding more
but 70 megabits per second or you know
which is again 20 MHz is a reasonable
deployment some are 10 but most are 20
or 40 right um you know um is uh is is
more than it's hard to think of mobile
applications that really need that much
throughput okay and um so most of the
users using much less than that so in
this this case I mean honestly so here
we've got eight times this would be 560
megabits a second I don't know you know
that probably is enough capacity for
probably support 200 300 400 500 users
you know it it's hard to know but let me
show you the other way we share and
that's tdma and then in this case we go
and share some in one this would be say
one millisecond and then another
millisecond we would go and share with
uh we do you know distribute to these
users and of course those techniques can
be combined now a more complex thing to
explain like what happens to these guys
when they're not getting there's not a P
cell around them okay and we have we've
solved that it's just honestly I think
it go beyond the scope of this talk but
it's a question that can be answered if
you'd like to come and and visit us okay
I don't I don't want to dismiss it it
was a difficult problem to solve but we
solved it so that these guys stay alive
even though they're not being spoken to
okay um or I should say stay attached
and then the best thing about P cell is
we can handle multiple protocols at once
and this is very very exciting um here
here we have the VR are not just you
know be release 8 say which we limited
to 64 quam you could do release 10 you
can go to 256 quam and because because
we're getting such sinr that's actually
a realistic um um it's a a realistic
coding scheme that we think we can
achieve um although we don't have Rel
estate devices just yet and also we can
do something we call P cell native A P
cell native device would have a tiny
fraction of the uh of the complexity of
an LTE device I mean there's no myo so
you don't need any mop processing the
device there's no shadowing so we we
don't need receive diversity or transmit
diversity there's only one antenna
needed okay it's only one RF chain and
um we don't and again we don't need
anywhere near the level of error
correction I mean that demo you saw you
might have seen the video drop out once
once in a while even with the lab radios
but it hardly ever it did at all there's
there's no um you know there there was
no all the turbo coding was completely
turned off when I was the de the demo i
showing so we've got a very robust
system so it means that now you can make
a phone which is much less expensive and
so we've been talking about pel phones
that are just pel and then I don't know
if you go out of the pel coverage area
you're stuck with maybe Wi-Fi or
interestingly enough Pell phones which
are Pell and then when they go out of
the coverage area they have 3G 3G is a
highly very mature technology one
chipset pretty much supports all the CH
the protocols and so on all the patents
have expired for the most part um so it
is um so this case like um user five
would be receiving in the same spectr
using the same infrastructure P cell
native uh user three uh user four would
be receiving release eight they'd be
limited 64 quam uh meanwhile user
one over there would be receiving uh
release 10 we're not we don't use any of
the LT LT Advanced features other than
the higher uh coding rate all right so
uh yeah what is the failure mode what is
the failure mode when you run out of
capacity well it does is it begins to
divide up the users uh the same way TD
CDMA at some point it's it it'll be just
like um it'll be similar to LTE in the
sense that um you know your your Ser
your performance gets worse and worse
right as you get less and less capacity
but there's a difference I mean there's
an upper limit I think it's about 200 or
something for what an EOD B can support
because everybody's getting their own
eodb we have no upper limit in terms of
the number of users you can just keep
adding VRI so it won't go dead on you
won't you won't go and say hey dude I
can't even you can't even connect all
right it will connect you whether your
device feels it's being starved at some
point or not you know is is um of course
how the device device is designed and
different devices we've tested actually
have different starvation Behavior okay
so if you're making a phone call would
it break up oh okay so I think what
you're asking is a different question
that's a a quality of service question
the scheduling algorithm that tells that
would tell this system how to allocate
when the system is oversubscribed
there's more data demand than the system
can handle okay then then it comes down
to the scheduling ALG how you do it it's
very difficult I do not I tell you I
have huge admiration for the scheduling
algor that's been done with cellular and
the the sewn Technologies has been done
because it's a really really hard
problem because you're not just dealing
with sharing um you know a limited
resource you're dealing a sh a limited
resource has this exponential drop in
performance as you get toward the edge
so the question is if the guy's on the
edge he's watching video should I let
him keep watching video because he'll
take down the rest of the cell he gets
further from the center right or do I
cut them off and you know you know so
those are the kinds of questions you
have to ask in a Cell system the nice
thing here is that everybody throughout
the coverage area is getting high sinr
so the question is is more like a
scheduling algor for a CPU in an
operating system you know or as I said
this is really like a virtual a
virtualization of
radio another way to look at this I mean
the OSI model goes down to level one for
the physical layer in in some ways P
cells like level zero I mean because
this is this is level one right here
well what's underneath level one you
know right the radio to have is that
what the radio each have one ant eight R
there eight radio heads in this example
and this so each oh so there's this
example there's four four four antennas
and there'll be eight users and what
type of antennas are they what we're
using right now is little dipoles um the
spectrum that we have for our use is uh
we have some 2.6 we have some um two
some 1 point I hav't
what's about um we have okay we have
some other we have 900 as well of course
is is open for us to
use
um okay then uh let me show you some
simulations so um release 8 um I'm just
about out of time is that right keep
going okay we'll just cut off the the
video from the outside world all right
so release a um allows you this shows
Sprints locations in this coverage area
which is down San Francisco our office
in the lower right corner so release
eight um um allows you go up to MMO 4x4
release 10 8 by8 so we and then we
showed what would happen with 30 MHz
spectrum and 2.5 GHz and uh 20 watts and
we also for myo um and we um for release
10 we go all the way up to myo 8.8
Sprint's not using myo 4x4 there's no
four antenna phones that exist today
that I know of anyway certainly no eight
antenna phones but we want to still give
LT the benefit of the doubt for pel the
model shows a real phone phone which is
just a two antenna phone which is like
the U the minimum number antennas the LT
spec allows and um also we also want to
just show a comparison so here the power
the power limit is the same for your
question before 2.5 GHz and then here
it's one watt is all we're allowed to
use at 900 MHz obviously and we only
really usually find 15 megahertz we
didn't want to use the entire band um so
we we put 15 MHz for this me you have
eight radio heads that eight radio heads
but you know it be like had sped
spread a few feet apart you know what I
mean as opposed to separate buildings or
or other you know which give you really
nice angular diversity so we we don't
get quite as much angular diversity as
we would if we were um as when we're
doing a a larger um a more distributed
deployment but okay but this goes and
shows you right here what happens with a
30 loc 32 locations that um uh Sprint
has in this location and uh and as you
can see with and we have we modeled it
with 100 users per cell these are pretty
heavily loaded cells and you can see
they're saying 6 megabits per second per
uee uh even if you go to LT Advance now
you're doing myo 8 by8 this is myo 4x4
myo 8 by8 it really doesn't get that
great if you look at Pell at the exact
same locations um again going to a two
antenna phone a real phone that exists
today we're getting 6.7 megabits average
and it's really kind of fun that 900 MHz
at half the Spectrum at one watt it just
shows how how great UHF is compared to
microwave um you get 4.2 megabits a
second um then we go over here these are
the real rooftops remember I told you
about our buddies that have these line
of sight rooftops and you can see just
how random they are I mean it's very
they're just scattered okay it's
completely serendipitous as you can see
and we've also we're still at 100 users
per uh cell so it it still very big load
on it and as you can see when you have a
random arrangement of cells the
performance actually goes down in a
cellular system and and even as as it
does with the LT advance system in the
case of P cell as you can see the
performance actually goes up why because
we just have more locations um then the
Reason by the way the red area can't
really fill in is we are limiting the
power we'd like to use more power where
we have a wider space there okay in the
case of uh 900 MHz again the performance
goes up with the more dense locations
and this is even a more telling diagram
this really tells what the users
experience um you can't see the numbers
from the uh probably can't see it from
far back but right here is 30 35% of the
users are getting zero throughput okay
and then this shows the other users
again with LTE it gets a little better
20% are getting zero with LT Advanced um
but you see Pell has a very good rate
except in those those areas just are too
far away only I think about 3% are
getting nothing and then at 900 MHz
that's amazing uh you know about 7% of
the users are at Peak Performance for uh
you know of what what is available then
if we go to 220 rooftops again 100 users
uh 100 users per cell
this is a very I mean a 220 rooftops 100
per cell this is a massive deployment
okay in terms of capacity um and it as
you can see 40% of the users are getting
nothing and then a few are getting
something and LT Advance again 40% are
getting nothing it just LT requires you
to have a nicely arranged arrangement of
buildings sorry of uh cell locations and
again as they get closer you have this
big inell interference problem then um
with Pell as you can see the per
performance is quite uniform and it it
it it actually leans toward the peak and
as we get to UHF once again a full 20%
of the users are getting full Peak
Performance so then this shows uh soft
Bank in Tokyo um they have a thing
called um they have a they adopted this
antenna system um distributed antenna
system called um for wireless City
Planning they call it um is the name of
the service and um they have these eight
antenna things and they all because they
have fiber everywhere in uh Japan
they back call to these Broadband hotels
and they have these line cards which do
LTE and it's pretty awesome I mean look
at this coverage they've got and um here
we modeled everything under the under
the sun myo 2x2 4x4 8x8 myo 8 by8 with
Cooperative multipoint you'll see some
of the benefits of COA multipoint when
you can buy with m 8 by8 I think it's an
extreme situation the conditions are the
same as we did for the the last one
except for the power here here they
can't go much Beyond 250 mows if they do
they obviously spill into the adjacent
cells because they're so tightly packed
so it's kind of like Wi-Fi okay um and
with Pell we do model 250 Ms but we only
do it with a a real phone you know one
that exists today a two antenna phone
and then we also because we can we model
it what would we do if we had five Watts
okay um because we don't we we can
overlap all right and so again it's very
telling um if you look at myo 2x two um
you're really getting very very low
performance it is 1.1 you'll see in the
next slide there's only a few users who
getting anything gets a little B better
with 4x4 a little better with 8 by8
Cooperative multipoint with 8 by8 does
give you a little bit of a benefit here
but I mean you're talking about a phone
with eight antennas in it and then a
very very sophisticated Communication
System the other thing with Cooperative
multipoint I mean my most sensitive to
motion then you add Cooperative
multipoint it's very very sensitive to
motion you're at 2 and half GHz you're
talking about people that are not moving
that are on a cell Edge this really
benefits it's kind of a weird situation
yes so these are model numbers as
opposed to measured num model numbers we
we we
we I don't well okay we have run with
all all the carriers that we've done
modeling with we've spoken with their
technical teams and they've said that
that our models that we've done for
their Cellular Systems are fair um so I
we have our our confidentiality
agreements I think you know anybody who
has looked modeled a cellular system in
the United States get if you put 100
users per sell this is the results
you'll get okay um and the but anyways
the uh again if the model is not correct
and or somebody feels there's another
way to look at it we' very happy to go
and change them but it's our our our
goal is to go and try to be as accurate
as we can we were using the 3gpp uh
shadowing path loss model for both cases
in the case of pel what we're seeing
with 250 M which the same power as these
four simulations is 35 megabits a second
when you let us go to 5 Watts it really
is something astounding this is what
we'd like to eventually get to which is
you know complete coverage a near the
maximum throughput across the entire
coverage area and you can see that with
these again the modeling with 35% of the
users with myo 2 X2 and 4x4 there's zero
throughput and all of the data rate
comes from a few users of course that
the you know in terms of average data
rate again myo 8 by8 we're modeling it
okay I just don't think anyone's ever
going to build 8 by8 phones and then
Cooperative multipoint does help okay
because it it gives you about uh I think
a 30% uplift on the cell edges which is
a big issue for this when you talk about
P P cell at 250 mows uh that's our
performance and this is what happens at
five Watts um in terms of where we go
and as you can see a full 10% of the
users are are actually getting the
maximum data rate which is about 53
megabits per second all right so um as
far as our business um there's no
significant technology risk that remain
it's been 10 years of work of just
solving One Challenge after another um a
lot of people asked what is the one
thing you did what's the one invention I
I wish there was just one um there was
some core concept we came up with but it
you know it need to be made practical
which took years of work and then after
it made practical we need to make it
commercial commercial ready uh which
included um you know for example making
compa with LTE and so forth we wouldn't
have bothered solving the calibration
issue if we didn't have to work with
existing devices and so forth I mean
that in itself has value I think to the
wireless world even independent of what
we're doing here with Pell but all these
problems had to be solved so there was a
Deployable system that's again my view
of the way we do things obviously
devices exist in the market there's no
Spectrum work we can look at license or
unlicensed Spectrum this is another
discussion we're happy to have with you
again it's it's a bigger discussion than
I can do in this meeting It's Tricky but
we have a way that we can make use of
existing Spectrum so for example the 700
megar Spectrum which is completely
saturated by carriers it's actually kind
of amazing to watch it through the day
um it's great Spectrum but it's
saturated okay we can simultaneously use
that Spectrum without interfering we can
deploy in small large areas and we we
don't really have competitors right now
um and we've been contacted Now by half
of the mobile operators in the last two
months uh you know there's 1.2 trillion
dollars of of Revenue that's um brought
into the mobile operators worldwide um
we're just we're just a little company
and we are just overwhelmed operators
representing 600 billion of that have
been have met with us all right and
we're actively engaged with as see
two-thirds of them right now um we've
been doing due diligence we've gone
through this whole process where people
are putting the attaching the stuff to
it and seeing what on it works and so
forth and um they're you know we've
often had the things said that they've
never seen such good results with their
LTE and uh analyzers when they're
looking at uh what they're seeing um the
other thing we've been connecting with
is all these non-operators it's actually
most of the people we speaking to and
again it it's you can't really uh we try
to measure in the number of companies we
talking about we said it's easier just
look at their annual revenue it includes
Stadium holders Spectrum holders mobile
platform holders mobile device makers
mobile silicon makers infrastructure
players the people own the real estate
you know we've had three separate
companies proposed to offer us rooftops
in Manhattan it's overwhelming uh it's
just been crazy um so we are we'd like
to do a uh our first l
um and um Wi-Fi LA and venue Wi-Fi we
call it launching in the fourth quarter
um it depends on who we work with and
exactly how it comes together and then
uh we uh we can do a widespread
deployment in other words hand it to
them to do deployment we see our
business perhaps being more like a Dolby
in the end of end of all this let other
people make the infrastructure and uh
let the other people run be the carriers
put in the servers and so forth and what
we would like to be is a software
defined radio company that provides a
software runs on these servers and that
is it thank you very much I'm sorry I
ran
over